need motivation watch top 10
with believe nation
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one kick yourself forward i think
comparing yourself to others is actually
fantastic i think most people aren't
even doing it enough
the challenge is people do it
incorrectly the problem is people
compare themselves to others as a way to
kick themselves down you look at
somebody else who's done a lot more than
you you say wow there's so much better
than me i can never do it and that's
kicking yourself down what you need to
do
you flip it and say wow that person has
done so much that's what's possible
i'm comparing my beginning to their
middle or to their end which is an
unfair comparison they can get there
therefore i can go chase my dreams down
as well
that's a kick forward most people kick
themselves down what you need is to kick
forward but without the kick you stay
stuck so if you want to say exactly
where you are don't compare yourself to
anybody you want to move forward compare
yourself in a loving way forward this is
the classic story of roger bannister who
broke the four minute mile where it was
supposed to be impossible to break the
four minute mile nobody was ever
supposed to be able to do it and then he
did it and everybody thought your body
would break down and that it just would
never ever ever happen and then roger
bannister did it and then what happened
lots of other people did it high school
kids did it people around the world have
done it why because they saw somebody
else do it
when you can compare yourself to
somebody else and see that they can do
it that can be
the inspiration to move yourself forward
again the kick forward if you just look
at that and say wow he's superhuman i
can never do it then you're right you
stay stuck but some people the people
who often win the people who also have a
happier life look at that and say
i can do something similar
and people did
i actually heard about that roger
bannister story through les brown and
when people ask me who is my favorite
motivational speaker who who do you
think is the greatest speaker of all
time i say les brown
i don't i don't know who touches les
brown i mean there's so many great
speakers so many amazing people out
there i've had a good fortune of
connecting with a lot of them but man
les brown when he gets on a tear
it's something different he takes you to
a different world and i remember when i
first heard him like holy cow this guy
is so good
and it was at the start of my
career of filming videos and making
content and i thought how does he how
does he know those
scripts and how does he memorize those
lines and how does he just speak for an
hour and not need notes or a powerpoint
or anything else like this man is crazy
it's impossible i could never get that
good
and i used to compare myself in a
negative way like i could never be less
brown
and then somewhere along the line i
flipped it to say hey
i'm getting better
and i love what les is doing because
he's actually guiding the industry
because it's actually showing what's
possible that if he can do it then i can
do it too he's actually paving the way
for people like me to come up and be
speakers as well
and i actually had a good fortune of
last week being on
a facebook live with him where he was
interviewing me about my story like what
les brown is interviewing me about my
story is crazy how did this happen
because i used him
as an inspirational kick forward
see if you never see anybody who's like
you doing it it's really really hard
to get up and do
if you're the only person that you know
on your family and the only person you
know in your community the only person
you see online anywhere trying to do the
thing that you want to do it's really
really really really hard to stay
motivated but when you can see somebody
else when you can model success you can
have an example to follow
i think that makes the path easier
because it gives you more hope knowing
that it's possible the trick is again
the key is again that in the comparison
to somebody else you're kicking yourself
forward to say that's what's possible
not down to say i suck rule number two
figure out your who figure out your who
your who is your single most important
core value i wrote two books talking
about it your one word and built a serve
i believe that everybody has a single
most important core value and when you
figure what that is it gives you a road
map for the rest of your life so
you can pick up either book to figure it
out or just ask yourself what is my
single most important core value you
have to pick right now what was your
single most important core value more
than more important than others not your
list of 13 core values one what is it
for me it's believe so everything i try
to do is about believe that the videos i
make this video the the goal the hope
the inspiration is to try to make you
believe in yourself more maybe i
accomplish that maybe i don't but it's
always the intention going in so when
you figure out yours whether it's belong
or freedom or inspiration or motivation
or happiness or care or love or believe
or whatever it is when you figure out
what that is
one it gives you good perspective on why
you haven't been happy any time i'm not
happy it's because there's a lack of
belief in my life either belief in
myself and what i'm capable of or i'm
not spreading that belief to others same
thing for you you figure out your who
whenever you're not happy it's because
it's a lack of that in your life right
now
and so if you want to hit the next step
it's by breaking through another barrier
of your who my next level of greatness
is on the other side of even more belief
in myself i still lack belief in myself
to get to the next step and same thing
for you and so figuring out your most
important core value gives you
the area to work on you know what you
need more of in your life and gives you
a roadmap of how to actually get there
rule number three stop over preparing as
soon as you get an idea for something
just take action on it we spend so much
time in our heads overthinking over
planning over analyzing over researching
over preparing and then nothing happens
nothing gets created has that has that
ever happened to you you got this idea
that you think is genius and you spend
all this time over planning over
preparing overthinking and then you
never actually make anything
and then maybe a year or two goes by you
see someone else get rich off of your
idea
i'm still a recovering perfectionist
myself right i lost a 40 million deal
when i was 20 something
because i was just trying to be too
perfect and so teach yourself to
shortcut the brain out you got an idea
you're gonna do something about it if
the intention is positive if the if the
goal is to try to serve and to help
other people
idea action idea action idea action do
it rule number four take action have the
courage to take action so getting
clarity is a lot of people get stuck on
this step you get clarity over what you
want you know that you don't want to be
stuck here anymore great you're
supplementing it and you're watching
videos and you're listening to podcasts
you're going to events and you're
meeting people great
nothing still changes
nothing
still changes it works until you
actually do something you have to have
the courage to act so the point of
motivation isn't just to feel great it's
to give you
the five seconds of courage then go do
the thing that you need to do
to go do the push-ups that you need to
do to then make the video that you need
to make to write the book that you need
to write to make the call that you need
to make the things that you're afraid to
do that old you would never have done
or badly wants to now you're actually
doing it now you're actually taking the
steps you can watch all these videos
about running but you don't actually get
healthier until you run
right you will not get healthier by
watching people run you could say my
number one goal is i need to get
healthier i'm gonna do that through
running step number two is you're gonna
surround yourself with people who run
who are you're watching videos of people
who run great but nothing actually
changes in your health until three you
actually start to run it's why it's so
important that with all of these videos
i always say what's your plan of action
what are you going to do because if you
just watch the video there's that 35
chance of you actually following through
if you just get motivated you're
probably not going to take the action
but when you create the action plan
you're way more likely to take the
action so the point of being around
these people of of getting the
motivation for that thing is not just to
feel rah-rah hey i can do it but it's to
give you that five seconds of courage to
then actually go take the action that
you need to take
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five change your environment
start to change your environment so
the more you're around people who are
loving caring
ambitious living the life that you want
doing the things that you want having
the relationships you want having the
business that you want
are not
sitting there stuck and complaining
complaining complaining
that's complaining and blaming together
it's complaining people aren't stuck in
that mode
the more they pull you forward the more
the more it forces a more positive self
reflection
so if you're around
elon musk and oprah winfrey and marissa
peer and tony robbins and hopefully evan
carmichael you know the more you're
around these people the more you will
start to think like them the more the
way they see the world will start to
influence
the way you start to see the world and
it forces that self-reflection because
the easiest way to change your your
viewpoint on something is to change your
environment the fastest way to learn
japanese is to go to japan because
you're around it constantly so if you
want to be more loving be around people
who are more loving you want to be
around you want more self-confidence for
yourself
be around people who are more
self-confident rule number six be
intentional what's the most important
part of my morning routine it's
remembering the intention how do i want
today to go not just having a list of to
do's but actually writing down how you
want to feel and that message to
yourself to give you the extra push that
you need to move it forward come up with
your intentions
whether you want to do my method and the
night before write down your calendar
and how you want to feel or if it's just
a first thing in the morning you're
you're looking at your calendar that's
what i used to do before writing it down
i just pull up my phone
load my calendar and just see what was
on my list for today because i'd often
forget what am i doing today i don't
know i just woke up i'm tired i look at
my calendar and then with each one i
would just mentally go through instead
of writing it
how do i want to show up for this person
if i'm making youtube videos how do i
want to show up
on camera how do i want to show up for
my audience how do i want to show up for
you i would just mentally think about
that as i go through the day and i
basically wake up go to the bathroom
pull up my phone and start going through
my calendar
that's it and how i want to feel the
intention going through each individual
item on my calendar
what i love about this
is i find that i'm a little more
courageous at night compared to in the
morning i just had a day hopefully it
was a good day hopefully i served i
helped um it's often after i answer some
questions on instagram so i'm in the
service heart and mindset
and i think about how do i want to show
up tomorrow if you find that you have
more energy at night or more clarity or
more boldness at night then then do that
think about how do you want to show up
tomorrow what are your tasks write them
down and with each one just write down
what the intention is how do you want to
show up as a human for each one so not
just a list of to do's but how you want
to feel going into each one
look use even as an example every day at
2 30 i spend time with nina
okay
every day 2 30 take a break from
whatever i'm doing spend time with nina
we usually go outside for the walk with
the dogs uh if it's raining we'll stay
inside and do something together just a
quick break in the middle of the day to
spend time together and that's in my
calendar and on my calendar it says 2 30
half an hour break with nina
but i wrote down what's my intention
right so not just time with nina i wrote
down
have fun and make her feel loved
and i wrote something else down
yesterday but that's my that's my
intention for today have fun and make
her feel loved so last night i wrote
that down i'm looking at nina she's
lying in bed she's you know about to
fall asleep and i want to think how do i
want to show up for her tomorrow for our
break
have fun
and make her feel loved
so i look at that again this morning
and i look at it again right now
and then here's what's gonna happen at 2
30
2 30 i'm going to be done filming my
videos i'm going to look at my calendar
look at my sheet here let's say 2 30
time with nina have fun make her feel
loved
just that reminder
will make me show up differently
if your goal is to have fun if your goal
is to make somebody feel loved you're
going to show up slightly differently
i'm going to show up with more love with
more energy maybe pull in some kind of
joke maybe picking her up and turning
her in a circle something i'm going to
show up slightly different
because i reminded myself that it's not
just
a break
the intention is to have fun
and make her feel loved
and so if you do that for all of the
items on your calendar for every meeting
that you've got for every quiet time
that you got for every creative moment
that you've got how do you want to show
up if you can write it down i love the
night before and then under each one how
do you want to show up that prime
when you look at it just before you go
into the task will help you show up as
you'd like as your most bold courageous
proud self rule number seven
get clear what is the life that you want
what are the goals that you have for
yourself where do you want to be in your
health and your relationships and your
business your finances
what do you actually want out of life
not what somebody else's perfect life
looks like right you go on instagram and
you see people
living on the beach and and rolling
around in money like that maybe that's
what you want but maybe it's not what
you want and we get pulled into all
these different directions because we
don't have clarity over what we actually
want so what do you actually want what
do you want out of life where do you
want your business to be what kind of
company do you want to run what are the
what are the ethics and morals that your
company is based off of who do you want
to serve and how do you want to help
them how do you want to show up in your
relationship who are you looking for in
your partner if you already have a
partner you know how do you want to show
up better for them
all of the things that matter to you to
get as clear as possible so that when
you see somebody else's doing something
else
and they're happy
great you don't have to go do it because
you're happy chasing down your goals
part of the challenge is we see other
people who are happy
and often it's not even real happiness
is just you know fake happiness for the
camera but you see somebody who looks
happy you know that you're not happy and
you think well maybe if i did that then
i'll be happy you know maybe if i go
write a poem like they did i'll be happy
and then you start to write a poem and
because i hate writing poems right so
it's getting clear over what do you
actually want in your life who's the
person that you want to be
and again from your finances to your
your business to the relationships to
your
to health the different areas of your
life get as clear as you can on the
things that you want out of your life
rule number eight take that risk the
biggest risk is not taking a risk at all
i love it so many people are so afraid
to follow their dreams to have this big
idea that they have that they want to go
off and accomplish we have this big
vision for ourselves and we're so afraid
of making the wrong decision that we do
nothing
that you see this big goal and you have
three four or five potential paths and
you have limited resources limited time
limited money limited abilities and you
want to say i need to make the perfect
decision because if i make the wrong one
it all falls apart
and as a result we get paralyzed by fear
and we do nothing and that's the biggest
risk of all that's when you see somebody
else making tons of money off your ideas
that's when you fast forward 10 years
and you still haven't done anything
you're still in the exact same position
that you are now meanwhile lots of
people have taken that idea that you had
and are crushing it
and so the way to get over it is to
recognize
that as soon as you get an idea you need
to find some small way to test it and
that you don't have all the answers and
that's okay and that you're going to
figure it out along the way
don't be
naive like i was to think that you can
create a business plan and it's going to
be the perfect business plan you're
going to have all the answers figured
out
and then you're just going to execute
that business plan because as soon as
you finish writing your business plan
and you get out into the world and you
start testing your assumptions you'll
find out that you made a lot of mistakes
that a lot of what you thought would
happen didn't happen you couldn't
predict the future you couldn't predict
how customers would react you can't come
up with the perfect plan just sitting in
your apartment sitting on your couch
going to the library you have to
actually get out and start talking to
customers test your assumptions that was
my biggest problem in my first business
i spent three months working on the
perfect business plan and then when i
got out to market i realized a lot of
what i thought was going to happen a lot
of what i thought with the reactions
would be is now what actually happened
and that set me behind
and so being attached to that perfect
idea understand that that doesn't exist
there is no perfect plan there is no
perfect idea as soon as you get
something in your head as soon as you
get an idea for something to do
then find some small way to get out and
start testing it
find some small way to get out and start
seeing are you getting yeses are you
getting traction do you even enjoy this
a lot of times these big goals that we
have for ourselves when you get into it
you want to be a youtuber great you
start making videos you're like yeah i
don't really like that go figure that
out as soon as possible people wait
years before they go out and try their
first attempt at it
and then they realize you know what that
wasn't for me and so i strongly
encourage you to one as soon as you get
an idea for something something you want
to test out something that you think
might work find some immediate way to
test it on a small scale don't take a
big risk don't go mortgage your house
don't go take out a giant loan i hate
spending money telling making money find
some small way to get started rule
number nine be aware of trigger wards
figure out what your trigger words are
what are your trigger words what are the
things that you say to yourself that
keep you small that keep you scared that
keep you safe that keep you from living
your dreams what are the trigger words
that you use so for me
it's scary difficult and hard whenever i
say scary difficult to hard
those are the things that have become my
trigger words and now i have to go do
the things because i said them because i
wrote them i texted them i said them i
thought them right when you when you
figure out what your trigger words are
then
whenever you say them it's an indication
of here i am again plain small here i am
again telling myself that i can't do it
here i am again accepting
these reasons that i no longer want to
accept being afraid is a classic one for
a lot of people well i didn't do it
because i was afraid and we've accepted
you've accepted the fact that you're
afraid as being a good enough reason for
you not to do the thing that you want to
do
and i would like to challenge that and
say that's no longer good enough reason
nope not anymore not for you not for
what you're capable of not for where you
want to go enough for the impact that
you can have nope not a good enough
reason anymore let's go
so if you just sit and think about what
are the trigger words that you say what
are the what's the language that you use
that keeps you small scared protected
that you no longer want to be good
enough reasons that you want to be free
of rid of
and that we're taking from our
subconscious mind automatic patterns
into our conscious and to know i am
going to make a change in my life i no
longer want to be this person i need to
evolve and grow and get better and be
better because i'm capable right you
so when you figure out your your trigger
words and try to cope with them it's a
good exercise to do right now what are
the words that you tell yourself
when you're scared when you're afraid
when you've got big ideas and you talk
yourself down from them what are the
what's the language you use you can
start by just taking on mine scary
difficult hard or you can come up with
your own but the idea becomes anytime
you see yourself using that language
it triggers you
to then make a shift to say oh okay
because i said that because i said scary
difficult or hard now i'm going to do it
just because because
i'm the kind of person who does scary
who does difficult who loves heart
and when you can take those words that
have previously disempowered you and
flipped them so that they be they become
empowered for you that's how you start
to shift your identity forward at the
end of the day the thing that matters is
is how you feel about yourself when
you're by yourself the language you use
to talk about yourself the messaging you
have to yourself when you look at
yourself in the mirror when you're going
to sleep when there's nobody else around
you because when you
can build that self-belief when you can
build that self-love when you can build
that self-confidence that self-esteem
that becomes
the rocket fuel for you to build the
great life for you your family the
people around you and create the impact
that you know you're capable of having
rule number 10 the last one before our
very special bonus clips be better have
a routine that challenges you
to be a better human this is why i make
these videos honestly this espresso
series is supposed to be a morning
series that we release five days a week
to help you start your day with a shot
of espresso with with some love with
some encouragement with people who are
doing more than you you may never meet
me you may never meet john ashraf you
may never meet bill gates or oprah
winfrey or steve jobs or the people that
i profile on this channel but you can
learn you can learn from them i learn
from them i start my day being around
them and the more that you're around
these people who are living the life
that you want that have the belief
systems that you want you will start to
adopt those as your own as well because
the people around you probably aren't
those people
right how many of the people around you
are the people that you look to and say
i want to be like that person that
person's got my life that person has my
ideal values that person is living the
life that i want to live
probably not
right and that's okay you can inspire
them to live a better life through your
actions but you need to get that push
and so the more you can create that
environment around you to help you get
it the greater the chances of you
actually going off and accomplishing
who's ahead of you in these things
one of the the greatest lessons i've
ever learned is that you can model
success that when you don't know what to
do
somebody has done this before you
somebody has figured this out
you don't have to come up with every
genius idea yourself this is the thing
that ended up growing my business my
first company when i wanted to quit on
my business partner i tried
so many different things on my own
and they never seemed to work but once i
had a model once i had a mentor once i
had a guide once i had a path to follow
it became so much easier and i got
success or looking at my youtube channel
spending five years on my own trying to
figure stuff out then once i got my
agent who gave me some coaching on being
better on camera my channel started to
take off
right so without the model i really
struggled with the model i did really
well so for all the areas of your life
that you want to fix who's done it and
here's the key there's no one person
who's done everything and i've got all
these people behind me on the wall
you know this is me
here when i'm eight or nine years old
and my parents behind me and then i've
got different people my wall for
different things if i look at being a
good father right i've got a 12 year old
son how do i be a great father i want to
be a great father like my dad is and i
don't want to be a great father like
steve jobs is because it didn't sound
like he was a great dad he had a lot of
other great things he was a great
visionary and i want to be a great
visionary like steve jobs but my
father's not really a great visionary so
you're pulling different things from
different people one of the mistakes you
make is you're looking for the perfect
mentor to teach you everything and when
they have one flaw we suddenly feel
cheated or ripped off or deflated
nobody's perfect we're all in search of
our own perfect life and you'll be able
to get that by pulling different people
for different things so once you've made
your list of all the things that you
want out of your life then go find your
different mentors and role models for
those things
if you want more belief in your life
great
watching my channel is probably going to
really really help you if you want more
fitness in your life great there's other
channels you can subscribe to right if
you want a better loving relationship
great there's other channels you
subscribed to for that or books or
podcasts that you can be around that the
more that you're around it the more that
is part of your environment you're going
to start to take those messages in it's
going to become a part of you you're
going to think the way those people
think and you're going to get closer to
actually achieving those goals if you
want to change your life change your
outcomes it starts with you changing
your consistent morning routine you have
to figure out what the best morning
routine looks like for you
and that can come from trying on
different people's hats and their
schedules but you have to have something
everybody has something nobody just
wakes up and then hopes that amazing
things happen not people who are
successful a lot of people wake up like
that though a lot of people do wake up
most people wake up and hope something
happens to them hopes that when the
lottery hopes to get the promotion hope
some big customer calls them right we're
just living in a land of i hope
something big happens to me but i don't
believe it's going to as opposed to
demanding excellence from yourself every
day and it begins with your morning
routine so how can you do it i'm gonna
give you a three-step process that i
think will help step number one is
figure out what makes you sore so i said
this is the most important part of my
morning routine
what makes you come alive and soar what
makes you feel like the work that you do
matters and you have to show up today so
for me i have to think of a message
every day i think about you guys every
day i i wake up i'm here in my toronto
condo it's hard to imagine that 300
million people have seen my videos and
that number doesn't make any sense right
and so it's easy just to wake up and
just continue to live my life me my dogs
my wife and my condo and and just
another okay day right
i have to remind myself that the work
that i do matters i think of a message
and then i share it and i take out my
phone and i post something to instagram
typically right and that sets me up that
reminds me that what i do matters is
meaningful i need to demand excellence
for myself what is it for you
maybe it's creating a piece of content
maybe it's making a video maybe it's
watching a video maybe maybe this is
part of your morning routine thank you
and it helps you soar right maybe it's
doing a good deed maybe it's meditation
or prayer or walking the dog or playing
in the in the sun like whatever it is
what makes you come alive you have felt
it before you have felt it before you've
had moments in your life where you were
bold confident unstoppable powerful
where you felt like you could take on
the world right but you felt like your
crazy ideas were possible you felt that
before i know you have the problem is
the problem is it's not consistent
you're not consistently feeling that way
and so you need to reverse engineer
yourself before you worry about taking
on other people's routines and ideas
which are definitely helpful reverse
engineer yourself to figure out when in
your life did you feel the most bold
confident powerful alive and what led to
that happening what led to that
happening and then put that into your
morning routine
demand it from yourself every day
right so it could be reading it could be
watching video all the things i talked
about it doesn't matter you felt it
before
reverse engineer what that thing was and
then put it into your morning routine
because if you woke up and you did the
thing that made you sore then would you
feel bold unstoppable powerful confident
every single day holy cow get ready for
a massive change in what your life looks
like over the next year step number two
is ask the high performance coach
question so again i'm going through all
of this stuff with brendan
i'm going through all this and my
favorite question
was the one i read
if i was a high performance coach is
what you should ask every day i like
this if i was a high performance coach
looking at my life from a high level i
would tell myself to remember that
because it's so easy why i love this is
it's so easy to look at other people's
lives and say what needs to be fixed
right
you can look at your spouse your friends
your team your parents your siblings you
know your high school mates whatever you
can look at other people and say
that needs to be fixed you got to go off
and do this right you you become the
high performance coach for other people
and what i love about this is that
you're looking at your own life
today as a high performance coach what
would you tell yourself
and then they have one at the end of the
day uh if i was my own high performance
coach i would tell myself this statement
about today so of all the things on here
this is it's a great format i like that
the best and so i would challenge you
for the next 30 days to ask yourself
that simple question if you were
a high performance coach looking at your
life from a high level you would tell
yourself to remember that what and then
step number three would be which three
people can you model their routine so
brendan you know he's got his and i'm
i'm modeling this for at least 30 days
i've added you know john assaraf a
friend of the channel been on a couple
times uh talks about writing down your
goals
every day and then and then touching
them right so i'll write down some goals
and then i and then i write them every
day now and i'm touching them right
that's what he does great again you got
to see what's going to work for you
maybe i do that for 30 days and stop
maybe maybe it's what i do for the rest
of my life i don't know you won't know
until you do it consistently enough so
pick three people who you like pick
three people who you respect who you
look up to say this is the kind of
person that i want to learn from and
then go investigate how they start their
day and then and then try on some of it
right you might love the rock and he
works out for four hours a day you may
not be able to do that but you could
work out for an hour a day right because
maybe you're doing nothing every day
so it's a good starting point like just
get to the gym and start working out
every day right so pick three people who
you love look up to respect admire and
then go research what are their morning
routines and how can you apply one thing
from each of them to see if it works for
you chasing down your dream is scary
chances are nobody around you has done
anything close to what you want to do
and they don't understand you they think
you're crazy well you know what here's a
news flash you are crazy and you need to
embrace your crazy ideas right now or
you'll regret for the rest of your life
that you never took action so i'm a big
believer that you need to trust your
crazy ideas that when an idea comes to
you you have to go off and do it you
have to teach yourself that you are a
genius therefore you come up with genius
ideas and you need to birth them into
existence because it came to you
therefore it's good at least that's what
i tell myself and here's a quick example
i started a new channel last week
featuring ig lives of different
entrepreneurs one of the things that
frustrated me was that people your
heroes people that i love that i look up
to that you look up to are going live on
instagram every day and the lives
disappear in 24 hours it's just a
function of instagram is after 24 hours
the lives go away nobody can see them
anymore and i was frustrated for myself
and for you and that all this great
wisdom was being lost but i was also
frustrated for them for the for the
thought leaders for the experts for your
heroes that they're creating this
amazing content to help people and then
it just goes away and so i wanted to
help protect their legacy preserve their
wisdom and also have something for you
guys to be able to go back to again and
again and again
access to thought leaders and experts
and heroes and so i thought what if i
just started a channel with their ig
lives and i came up with the idea on a
friday and then on friday we launched
on friday i started with my own live and
we we had a live of one other person and
i put them up and we launched a channel
set up the email address set up the
banners set up the channel art set up
the playlist set up the rules and then
started training my team on how to do it
and so now we've got i don't know how
many videos a bunch of videos that have
been put up since we've launched a
channel and and that needs to be the
speed at which you start to move that
you get ideas and you don't sit on them
how many ideas have you had that you've
been sitting on for weeks for months for
years
when i when i travel and i meet
different entrepreneurs it it saddens me
so much to see so many people
have had a dream
for a decade plus
and still haven't done anything with it
the biggest problem is you're just not
acting on it and so you have to protect
your dream you have to you have to find
a spot that makes you come alive makes
you believe that you can do it but
protecting your dream doesn't mean doing
nothing on your dream right you have to
act even when the people around you
don't understand you think you're crazy
because again you are nuts it's amazing
and you have to embrace your crazy ideas
as time has gone on i become less and
less a fan of goal setting
and i love the idea of quarterly goals
over annual goals over decade-long goals
because the timeline is shorter
and why i'm less a fan of goal setting
is because
the more you're actually growing the
less likely you're actually able to
predict where you're going to be
so
i really hate 10-year goals five-year
goals 10-year goals if you think about
where you were five years ago think
about who you were five years ago
five years ago look at the calendar five
years ago from today
in the past who are you
you think that person
could predict where you would be
ten years ago
10 years ago i just started my youtube
channel
i had a couple videos up 10 years ago i
said i'd never want to write a book 10
years ago i wouldn't imagine that i'd be
here every year
making videos for a youtube channel with
300 million views in puerto rico because
brendan burchard invited me to his
mastermind group
to speak on stage in front of
all these successful entrepreneurs i
wouldn't have predicted that like with
with zero accuracy
and same thing for you ten years ago you
had no idea that you'd be here not if
you're growing and this is the big
caveat not if you're growing like if you
can predict with accuracy where you're
going to be in 10 years
you can hit it but it's just way small
compared to what you could have done and
it means you haven't grown in the past
decade
and so that's my main beef against goals
and and
having shorter goals having new miracles
can be great can be great like i want to
get 10 million subscribers on my main
youtube channel that's a good goal
but if i set that as my 10-year goal and
that's the only thing i'm gonna do then
it's wrong because probably in three
years i should jump off and do something
else
right i've been fortunate that
i've been doing youtube for 10 years i
still love it it's still amazing but
chances are your 10 year plans you
should jump up in year two and go
through something else because that
thing is actually better for you because
you've grown as a person
so at least that's great the advice that
instead of annual goals set it down to
quarterly goals because goals are still
helpful
they're so good to kind of track your
progress to know that this video did
better than that video that this
customer brought in more money than this
customer that are you doing enough
action to go and get the business that
you want
those are great
but as a macro
thing that's leading your decisions
i think the longer you stretch it out
making decisions you want to do things
that will serve other people serving
others is hardwired into us they did
fmri scans of the brain and when you
help other people it hits the same part
of your brain as food and sex more than
receiving more than getting gifts is
helping others serving others being of
use you want to wake up every day and
feel like
the work you do matters that you're
having an impact we all want to go off
and have an impact you are built to
serve and so already in your decision
making does it serve somebody else does
it help other people in some way if it's
yes you're making progress in the book i
go through a three-step process who i
how so who your one-word most important
core value what do you stand for who are
you you have one word that is more
important than all the others so
belief is my most important core value
and so already the decisions that i make
are through the lens of belief this
video is about belief i hope it's it's
my intention i may not always execute on
it as best as i can but it's always my
intention and so if you understand what
your one word is then it allows you to
make your decision making process a lot
cleaner a lot simpler a lot easier next
is your why your purpose comes from your
pain your why comes from your pain the
thing that you want to help and serve
other people with the problem that you
want to solve is the same problem that
you went through the people who you will
love serving are the people who are
currently struggling with the thing that
you struggled with
your purpose comes from your pain and so
whatever was the most painful moment in
your life the moment where you felt the
lowest the worst the the most worthless
as a human being your purpose for the
rest of your life is to help other
people who currently feel that way so
think about who you used to be who you
were five years ago whenever you were
struggling the most there's lots of
people who currently are like you used
to be you want to go serve them and then
the how becomes
how did you get through it how did you
get out of that problem you may not even
be fully out of the problem whatever you
struggled and suffered with you're not
done you're still growing you're still
learning you're still improving you're
still climbing that staircase you know
of knowledge and growth but every time
you take a step up on the staircase you
can reach back and pull somebody else up
one more step one more step the more you
learn and grow the more you can pull
people up with you and so however you
got out of the hole even though you're
not done
you're better than you used to be
there's lots of people who currently are
who you used to be and so however you
got out becomes a recipe to teach other
people as well happiness comes from
knowing who you are and then having the
courage and confidence to step out onto
that ledge step out onto the ledge the
ledge
and go live it and it'll be you
because it's hard because it's tough
because you're going to get judged
because we're constantly comparing our
version of happiness to somebody else
i'm here in puerto rico brendan brachard
invited me down to speak to his
mastermind group
these people pay 30 to 50 000 a year to
be a part of it and i'm honored to be a
guest and
the thing that i see consistently from
all the people who are here right
imagine if you're dropping 30 to 50k to
be here how much are you making
so that you want to come down right
everybody's doing the thing that makes
them come alive and that's the secret of
entrepreneurship at least the ones who
are successful
that your version of happiness is going
to look different than somebody else's
you're a weird duck that's awesome go
live it
brendan came on stage and started
talking about his daily routine
brendan doesn't do anything
work related typically until about one
o'clock he wakes up he walks the beach
he meanders he plays with his cat he
does all of these things that get him in
the right mental framework and his first
call is one o'clock
so he said i want you guys to try
something
tomorrow go and walk the beach right
walk the beach
try that first thing in the morning he
moved the start time we're supposed to
start at nine the start time to 10
o'clock because they wanted us to walk
the beach just as an experiment to see
and i i did it i went out i walked the
beach and it was good
but it's not the thing that brings me
happiness
right living in a
tropical paradise
it's not my thing
i like concrete
i like the concrete jungle
i like being
steps away to everything
i like insane high speed internet you
know
the things that make me happy are going
to be different than brendan burchard
will be different than you
it's just about figuring out what the
heck is the thing that makes you happy
and then spending as much time as
possible doing that thing if you want to
be thinking two to three years ahead and
still have success today then you need
to make sure that you have existing
momentum right now entrepreneurs we're
dreamers we love thinking about what we
can make two to three years down the
line it's an easy place for us to live
the biggest problem isn't thinking two
to three years ahead it's right now it's
that you're lacking momentum right now
in your business you're a genius the
only thing you're missing is momentum so
me personally i've actually tried to go
and do the opposite of this advice most
of the time uh it's so easy to live two
to three years out that i want to now
focus on mission what am i trying to
accomplish the big thing that's never
going to happen right i want to solve
the world's biggest problem i don't
think people believe in themselves
enough and that's what i wake up every
day trying to help solve but it will
never happen
and then what am i doing right now as
opposed to getting lost in what i can do
in two to three years because again i
think it's so easy just to live there
and then not bring it back to what am i
doing today to build momentum so i've
really tried to teach myself that as
soon as i get an idea for something to
start building momentum around it not to
get stuck in planning mode right it's
easy to get stuck in planning mode
here's where i want the plan to be in
two to three years you have to do jeff
bezos can think about where he wants to
be in two to three years because he has
an army of people doing work right now
building momentum on what's currently
happening if you're a solo entrepreneur
and you're just living in the future and
nothing's happening right now you're
never going to build that future so as
soon as you get an idea at least for me
i've been trying to teach myself i take
immediate action towards it it could be
something
really big it could be something like
when i wanted to build a house
i just decided i'm going to build a
house and then a year later i had my
house built right from finding a dead
property that was empty to excavating to
building a 5 000 square foot modern home
within a year i had my home built from
just having the concept and the idea
right
teach yourself that as soon as you get
an idea you don't just sit you don't
just plan you don't just tinker you get
out into the world and start doing i'm a
big believer in altering your
environment i don't think that it has to
be physical to start so let me break
down a couple ideas for you that i think
will help one
your physical surroundings of where you
are right now what's on your wall what
you watch the youtube videos that you
consume hopefully my channel the books
you read all of that starts the process
of changing what gets into your mindset
more important than the physical
environment is this
it's what you're putting in here and so
you can start that from your home you
can start that from wherever you are and
i gained massive new belief in myself
from the video so my own channel from
consuming the content from guys like dan
and brendan richard and tony robbins all
these people every day in my head it
pulls me up it makes me think bigger
makes me feel like there's something
more and injects myself with the belief
and so you can do that right now
immediately look at your habits look at
your routine look at the people you talk
to look at the the podcast you're
listening to in the videos you're
watching and is it part of a daily
practice it needs to be a daily practice
that you're putting that into here to
help you start playing a bigger game a
key reason why you are not in an amazing
place right now is because you do not
have amazing people around you think
about it how many of the people that you
hang out with consistently
make you feel amazing force you to grow
and push you to be a better version of
yourself you can't do this alone the
people around you need the change so you
can change so i recently came back from
a mastermind group in puerto rico with
brendon burchard and a bunch of super
successful people and one of the things
that i loved the most was how
he works with his friends and there's so
many people who say don't work with
friends don't with family but he's built
this group
of people who love working together
some have joined his team some are
business partners in different ventures
where they're genuine friends and
they've been friends for in some cases
over a decade
i love that model i love working with
people that i that i know that i'm
connected to i love working with friends
i don't see it as business is one thing
and personal something else maybe that's
just me i would much rather work with
somebody who i get along with than just
have a you know business relationship
and
that in particular made me think of my
friend mark drager and mark's got a a
marketing company called phantom media
we had a podcast together called the
celtic podcast you want to go check it
out and i've known mark for over a
decade
and
he sent me a message not too long ago
saying that
what i need in a marketing partner for
my business isn't what he can provide
yet that he's still a little bit away
whether it's a year or two years or
whatever it is away from being able to
help me with what i need both from a
experienced point of view a resource
point of view uh uh you know team point
of view that he wasn't ready to help me
and that he felt like he was holding me
back that if i had somebody else then i
would grow faster
and
it never sat
right with me
until i went to brendan's event and then
what came back was realizing
i want to grow with mark i want to grow
with my friends i don't want to just be
at the top and then have a bunch of
business associates around me and then
my friends are like way down here right
i want to i want to build it together
there's value for me in building it
together beyond just a business roi and
i think ultimately long term it actually
leads to a better business roi
and i love that i love that brendan does
it and provided a model for what is
possible for me to be able to go off and
create and build and so whether it's
mark whether it's alex from toronto
dance salsa whether it's jeremy from the
youtube coaching business that that we
started together
i like being on the work with people who
i can call friends
and i want to be able to do that more
and so whether you come on board and you
you you bring on your friends or family
uh definitely being around people who
push you who make you feel energized who
built you up who you could see for the
next 20 years being people that you want
to hang with i think is really really
really really really really really
really really really really important
you are spending way too much time on
things that you hate doing that you
never want to be great at and it's
hurting your business
i'm here in puerto rico i'm speaking at
an event with brendan burchard his
mastermind group and one of the things
i've learned from people who've
accomplished a lot i've had big success
is that you are great at something right
you're you're the michael jordan of
something you have genius level talent
at something
but you're not spending enough time
doing it
you're spending too much time on the
things that you hate that you don't ever
want to be great at that you can respect
and say hey this is important for my
business but it doesn't mean that you
should be the one doing it
so i spoke at this event and i'm talking
entrepreneurs and they're thought
leaders and they want to have their
youtube channel they want to build up
their presence and brand name and
recognition and there's so many people
who when they get started they spend 20
minutes
recording a video
and then four hours editing it
to put the right graphics on to put the
right intro and extra music
now
if you are in the graphics business if
you are an editor then your stuff has to
look amazing
but if you're not
then you're training the wrong this is
the thing you're training
the wrong skill there's things in your
business that you're spending so much
time on that you never want to get great
at you're training the wrong skill you
should not be doing it
discounted it doesn't mean you
get rid of it completely it doesn't mean
that you disrespect it completely but if
you're spending 20 minutes recording a
video and four hours editing it you're
training the wrong skill you need to
switch it you need to spend four hours
recording it
four hours recording it and 20 minutes
editing it
or zero minutes editing it i don't care
because people who are watching your
videos if you're a thought leader
they're coming for this
they're coming for what's in your head
they're not coming for how great your
editing skills are
now that doesn't mean you disrespect the
editing doesn't mean you never hire an
editor doesn't mean you learn zero
but the thing that will get you to be
able to afford to hire an editor is
making awesome content that comes from
here because no amount of editing is
going to save it if your ideas suck
it's the thing that holds so many
entrepreneurs back from making videos
if you don't want to make videos if you
don't want to be on youtube awesome but
there's something in your own business
that you're taking that same equivalent
to so look at your calendar look at
where you're spending your time look at
how much time is actually being spent on
things that are moving the business
forward that you love that you could be
the greatest in the world potentially at
chances are that number is like five
percent
and you need to move it that needs to be
85
that's when you start creating magic
and it's not going to be perfect
releasing that video won't be perfect
you're gonna look at it and say man that
really sucks i would love to have better
lighting i would love that better sound
i would love that better editing i love
that better gear great
work towards it
but that can't be the reason why you
don't post and it can't be the reason
why you're spending all this time doing
work that you hate
you can only do so much by yourself
i love being an army of one right when
you get an idea you have to do something
about it you will it into existence and
if people don't want to help you then
you will it into existence being
nominated one
but there's a lot of different ways to
win
and you're going to win the hardest on
the thing that you're the best at
and so you start
and so you start and so you start
but you can't do everything
not very well
so you pick the thing this is the this
is the most important thing that will
help
give you leverage in your business to
help you turn from just kind of making a
little bit of money kind of making a
little bit of momentum to having massive
momentum to making way more
leverage
figure out the thing
that when you do is fantastic
and everything else almost doesn't
matter the greatest thing that you can
do for yourself is be proud of your
daily effort it's not about how many
likes or views or praise you get that
stuff doesn't actually matter it'll hit
you and make you feel great for a second
and then it fades the only thing that
matters is when you're all alone looking
at yourself back in the mirror are you
proud of the person that you are looking
at and for too many people
it's no
and i want to change that in this video
so i recently came back from brendan
burchard's mastermind in puerto rico
with some super high level people
about 25 of us sat around the table
masterminded for three days and a lot of
people i've profiled here on this
channel
and i normally
hate
these kinds of events that are
open that are loose that require just
networking and talking to people right
if there's a structure or if you need
help i love it if it's and just spend
the next hour and a half
mingling and talking to people i hate it
even the thought of it right now is
making me cringe i hate it so much
but when i got there brendan challenged
me to say
make sure you ask for help make sure you
don't just give give give give but that
you you leave here asking for help and
so
that's always been a challenge for me
networking events plus asking for help
we're hitting like both things that i
historically have sucked at and they
struggle with and so i decided i'm going
to be proud of my effort today i'm going
to go off and do it i'm i'm not going to
go home i'm not going to go back to my
hotel room right the hotel room was
super close
on that two hour break 90 minute break
three hour break i could have gone
back to my hotel room and done some work
i had lots of logical reasons why i
should go back and do work everything is
behind because i'm not working
but really it'd be an excuse because i'm
afraid because i'm afraid of staying
there because i'm afraid of not being an
instruction environment because i'm
afraid of just talking to people because
i'm afraid to ask for help and so i
decided i'm going to play fallout i'm
going to play for love i'm going to
maximize this time i've got here
i'm i'm taking this time off for work
because i need to develop the
relationships i need to get the help
that i need to get and i'm going to i'm
going to ask for it i'm going to i'm
going to be proud of my effort even if i
fail even if i suck even if it doesn't
work out i'm gonna be proud of my effort
and it wasn't the most uh amazing
result right it was awkward i was
standing around and trying to join
people's conversations it was super
awkward and cringe-worthy but i was
proud that i did it i was proud that i
tried i can look at myself in the mirror
and said i did that i tried my best pat
on the back i'm amazing
for other people who are there too
they're naturally extrovert they don't
understand what it is to be introvert to
be shy to join in on conversations to
not ask for help and how hard that can
be
so for them it was easy
to just start conversations and
introduce themselves to me it was really
difficult but self-worth self-love
self-pride comes from doing difficult
things that you don't think you're
capable of and so i was really proud of
my effort for doing it and if you did
the same thing it's something i still
try to do every day
to be proud of my effort in making this
video i want to be proud of my ever that
i tried my best to make the best
possible video yet
you may not achieve it it may not happen
but if every day you woke up and you try
to do the thing to make yourself proud
right the effort you're going to create
amazing amazing amazing things where if
you stay constrained
by just what you know and what you're
capable of and what you're good at you
never grow you just stay inside your
comfort zone forever and ultimately end
up hating your life working on your
weaknesses is great advice in basketball
but sucks for entrepreneurship because
there's no such thing
as a complete player in entrepreneurship
there's too many things to learn
this is the difference between the
finite game and the infinite game if
you're familiar with simon sonic's work
define that game is when you're playing
a game where there are certain rules
basketball has certain rules right
basketball kobe's on the floor for a
certain amount of time in every game
can't just have somebody come in and
come out if you bring somebody in kobe's
got to come out you only have five
players on your team at a time there's a
certain number of minutes in a quarter
right
there's rules
for entrepreneurship for life
there aren't as many rules
you get to play forever
in entrepreneurship
if you are the world's greatest
jump shot shooter
right take that equivalent
you're you're a billionaire
you don't have to go learn the other
things and it's in your best interest
not to
for you to be great at one thing but
then also go learn
websites and also go learn coding and
also go learn copywriting and also go
learn speaking and also go learn video
editing and also go
there's too many things
and you'll at best become average at all
those things
so you're a complete average person
entrepreneurship is the opposite
what you want to do is find a thing that
you could be the kobe bryant of you are
the best in the world at something
you're the best in the world at
something
something in demand something in need
something where you can help people
and then go all in on that
so it's got to be that combination of
what you love doing
with what there is demand for finding
your calling is easy i think it's crazy
that people don't know how to find their
calling i think it's
among the most important questions that
you need to figure out
in life like how are you living your
life without knowing why you're here
what your calling is how you're going to
serve the message you have the one
impact that you want to have it's crazy
you can't
live a happy fulfilled life until you
know what that is
and it's not that difficult and it just
blows my mind because when you figure it
out when will smith figures it out when
all these super insanely talented people
figured out the world's gonna change can
you imagine a world where everybody
has found their calling and is living it
i want to live in that world and so
that's why i'm trying to create that
world you've got a great idea
you know it can change the world you
know it could have a big impact you know
it could change the fortunes of yourself
your family the people around you you've
got a great idea you know it can work
you know it can work
the problem is you don't know if it can
work for you you believe in the idea but
you don't believe in yourself
and so here's what's happened why well
it's because you've tried and stopped
and started and stopped and started and
stopped and maybe saw a little bit tiny
results but then you lose the motivation
and you stop you've never stayed with
anything long enough to actually let it
see results and so you built up this
pattern inside yourself that says i
can't do it the idea is great but i
can't do it that's really at the core
if you really believe that you could do
it and you really believed in the idea
you'd be doing it and crushing it that's
the biggest difference is why lack of
belief is the world's biggest problem
the only thing you're missing is actual
sustained momentum against your ideas
because if you believe that you could do
it you'd be out there doing it
you believe in your idea
and how it could change the world but
you don't believe in your own abilities
to do it i'm gonna teach you a mindset
hack that if you can learn to apply will
help you eliminate your self-doubt your
fears your insecurities and step forward
confidently into whatever situation you
get yourself into and it's this
you teach yourself that you can learn
anything you can learn anything you may
not have the answers right now you may
not know how to do the crazy thing that
you want to do you've got big goals big
big dreams big ambitions you want to do
something big that's why you're watching
this channel right you're part of
believe nation you want to do something
big with your life i love it you don't
know how to do it you teach yourself i
can learn
anything
because what we often
struggle with is
you want to do something you know you
can't do it yet and then you associate
with that i suck
i can't do something so i suck
and that
attack
on your self-worth on your
self-confidence on your self-esteem
prevents you from actually going off and
creating something amazing right i think
i think you're a genius i think you have
michael jordan level talent at something
i believe that i don't just say it in
videos i believe that that's true
so whatever you're stuck on
instead of making yourself feel like you
suck that you're not good enough that
you're not capable of it
understand that it's just a skill set
that's missing the difference between
where you're at right now and where you
want to be
is the skills that you acquire and in
the action that you're taking
you're willing to take action
problem is you probably don't have the
skills yet to be where you want to be
that's okay
you tell yourself i can learn anything
learning becomes your superpower some
people are built to serve the world some
people want to have a giant mission a
giant vision you want to impact the
lives of millions of people that's me
that may be you if you're watching this
that's most entrepreneurs i think you
have a giant vision and you want to
change the world but some people
are built to serve the 25 closest people
to them if i look at my wife nina as an
example she doesn't have a giant mission
she doesn't have a giant vision but she
still wants to serve if you're not happy
if you're not happy in life it's because
you're not serving you're not serving
deeply enough to the people who you care
most about or you're not serving broadly
enough to have a big enough impact on
the people around you your community
your country your continent the world
right
so entrepreneurs are default too i think
we want to serve the world they did
functional mris on the brain functional
mris and they studied the impact
of serving of helping other people and
it showed that when you serve other
people when you get the satisfaction you
help somebody else out it touches the
same part of your brain
as eating food and having sex which are
both also pretty important things in
life i think you would agree
and so you're built to serve and and
they went deeper into the study and they
found that giving triggers it more than
receiving
so all of the
stories that we know of how giving is
great and santa claus and you know it's
better to give than to receive and all
this stuff right the things that we've
been told in our stories that have been
handed down to us is backed up by
science it's backed up by science
so if you're not happy right now
if you're a little bit low right now
the easiest path out is service serve go
help people if you woke up every day and
felt like the work that you did matter
to somebody either to again the closest
people to you like my wife who's still
in touch with their friends from
kindergarten in china
to someone like me who wants to have a
giant impact and reach a billion people
around the world if you're not happy all
you have to do is start to serve the law
of attraction definitely works most
people just get it wrong most people
only focus on the thinking part and not
the most important part which is the
action right law of attraction it's the
last five letters that matter a c t i o
a c t i o n six the last six letters
that matter action action action
thinking about it alone is not enough so
it's the two parts you get an idea you
want something into your life you want
to manifest something amazing you want
success in your business you want a
happy relationship awesome you want to
speak on giant stages whatever the thing
is that you want in your life awesome
you have a vision board amazing just the
fact that you're thinking about it
and believing in it is already a big
step ahead of where most people are most
people live in a negative zone most
people feel like their life is hopeless
that they can't make a change that
they're stuck where they are and guess
what happens they stay exactly stuck
where they are right what you focus on
ends up becoming your reality so yes
you're gonna focus on your new goal your
new habit the new thing that you want
into your life amazing you believe that
it's possible amazing you're putting up
a vision board with it on your wall
amazing you're researching and watching
videos like this every day amazing
that's great that's the first starting
point but nothing happens until you take
action
nothing happens until you take action
thinking alone is not enough
again it puts you ahead of most of the
most of the world puts you way ahead of
them but
you're still just going to be this super
smart super ambitious person sitting at
home not achieving your goals you have
to do something i look at my youtube
channel as an example uh my main channel
i want to get the 10 million subscribers
that's my next goal right we hit one we
hit two i got to hit 10. uh at the rate
that we're growing it's not fast enough
like it's going to take me way too many
years to make it happen so i need to
apply more pressure against it so
part of what i look at every day now in
my morning routine is i want to hit my
goal i want to get 10 million
subscribers on my youtube channel right
i want to be
you know one of the first
uh thought leaders experts business
person to have 10 million subscribers on
a youtube channel it's my next goal
great writing that down every day
doesn't make sure that it's going to
happen what am i doing
right writing it down can lead to
thoughts that then lead to action but
what am i actually doing well i'll tell
you what i'm doing now
one of the biggest things i'm working on
now big new initiative for my team is
i've got 6 000 public videos on my main
channel
and
i told my team
this week i want to go back and update
all of the thumbnails in all of the
titles across all my videos
that's a lot of videos right that's 6000
videos imagine doing split tests on all
of those videos
i asked for 10 a day and so two key
people on my team are working together
to come up with what the title is gonna
be and then the other ones doing the
graphic design to create the thumbnails
maybe it works the first time maybe it
doesn't
and it's a big ambitious project if you
think about it we got 6000 videos 10
videos a day
you know in a year if we did it for 10
videos every day we're just over half of
those videos assuming that they all work
out which they won't
so this is our test and if it works
awesome i might have that become
somebody's full-time job so that we can
do 20 slit tests a day 40 split tests a
day 100 split deaths a day i don't know
but it's happening to action right so it
starts with the idea if you have the
idea but you're not taking action you
won't get results if you just have the
action but you have no idea you're
running around with a chicken with your
head cut off you're you're going in
circles without any clear direction most
people
think too much and don't do enough
that's most people some people do too
much and don't think enough some people
need more planning but in general most
people are over planners and so watching
this video alone is not enough
it's a great start it might boost your
motivation it might give you an idea to
go off and try watching my content
watching dan lok's content alone is not
enough it's the essential first piece of
the ingredient it's it's essential
surrounding yourself with people who
build you up who make you believe who
give you ideas you can act on that allow
you to feel like your goals are are
possible that your dreams are within
reach is super important i do it every
day it's why i create all these channels
i think you should too you'll notice a
difference in how you think every single
day if you are creating content and
consuming content that builds you up
but then yourself to go take the second
step
it's why after every video i have a
question of the day or i have a three
point landing question because i want
you to take action you need to teach
yourself that after every video you
watch up to every podcast you listen to
after every book that you read
but that's not enough you have to do
something about it i'd rather you watch
fewer videos read fewer books listen to
fewer podcasts consume less
if you're taking action on the ideas
that come to you because most people are
just professional
consumers
and it's great that you're consuming
educational content because most people
are just consuming stupid content right
you hate your life so you go watch
netflix all day when you get home for
five hours and then go to sleep right
you're a professional consumer but
you're consuming
uh wasteful content just entertaining
content
so you've already taken a step above
right you're consuming educational
content that's the next step you're
consuming educational content amazing
but still that alone is not enough what
separates the people go off and achieve
their dreams from the ones who just have
things on a vision board is that last
step of taking action so your head only
understands a world that exists your
head is logical it's practical and so
whatever's been done can be done again
right it's logical and so if you've got
a job
at some company you know you can make x
thousands of dollars a year that's
that's safe that's logical that's
practical you know what can be done
it exists other people have done it too
you compound that with people telling
you to do the safe thing right go get a
job go take the safe path go take the
safe route and so there's a lot of
outside forces especially fear generated
that keep you on a small path keep you
on the safe path
and it's not necessarily wrong it's not
malicious
they're not trying to hurt you it's just
fear-based and so it's small you never
create amazing things when you're living
in a fear-based state and that's what
you're doing when you make big decisions
with your head
because your head only understands a
practical world that currently exists
now your heart your heart's a different
story your heart can create something
that's never existed before your heart
is where all the artists lives all the
all the game changers live all the
people who end up making massive change
in the world that's where they live
they're creating something new they say
i see something that other people don't
see
and i can go create it that's heart
you're creating something that hasn't
existed before that doesn't make sense
that's not logical that's not practical
there's nothing to tell you that this
could work but you feel that it can work
that's where i know you guys are at if
you're watching this channel you're
watching this video that's where i know
you're at
the problem is living inside your head
instead of living inside your heart
so what happens is you'll have some days
where you're living in your heart you
have some days where you feel bold
motivated excited feeling like you're
capable like maybe you could actually do
this you'll have some days i'm going to
switch my hand my hands getting tired
i'm holding the video you'll have some
days where you'll actually feel that way
like maybe i can i could be the person i
am bold maybe you watch a video maybe
just wake up you get inspired you have a
great dream something happens you have
this moment where you just feel bold
powerful and stop her and say today's my
day i'm going to go off and do it and
crush it right we've all had those
moments
but then you wake up the next day and
you're back to being in your head
telling yourself i can't do this i
didn't go to school for this i don't
have the money for this i don't have the
talent for this i'm not good enough for
this i i'm not brave enough or creatures
ask for this right that's all your head
talking to yourself
when you haven't fully decided
on something big what ends up happening
is your head and your heart fight
so if you haven't fully decided that you
want to start this business that you
want to hit your 10 million subscribers
on youtube that you want to fill in the
blank your big crazy ambitious goal when
you haven't fully decided on it your
head and your heart are going to fight
they should fight
because it's not logical it's not safe
it's not practical if it was it wouldn't
be a big idea your big amazing bold
ideas are not logical they're not
practical and they're not safe
and so your head is always going to say
whoa whoa whoa slow down this is scary
and most of the time you're going to
listen to your head and the people
around you will tell you listen to your
head
what you need to do is fully decide what
you need to do is decide that this is
going to happen that it's not an option
anymore that there's no maybe i'll do it
maybe i won't
your heart has to decide the big
decisions in your life should you go
move to that other country or other city
should you go marry that person or not
should you go
take that job or not should you go start
that business or not big decisions with
your heart and then you use your head to
help you figure out the how making
decisions for your life based off of
what other people expect you to do
is the fastest way to hate your life
most people actually hate their lives
most people are not doing the thing that
they could be great at and they're
judging you for you going off and
chasing down your dream listening to
them
is the fastest way to crush your dreams
and never achieve the michael jordan
level greatness that you have inside you
you're a weird duck this is one thing
that i have learned
from all my travels from all the
entrepreneurs i've visited around the
world i'm a weird duck and so are you
you're a weird duck you like weird
things you're not normal you don't want
to be normal you don't want to be normal
you do not want to be normal
and yet you judge yourself based off of
what other people expect a normal person
to do
and it's time to stop
and and i'm
leaning into it more and more and more
and more and more
and i hope i can give you permission to
lean into it more and more and more as
well
i'm here with beautiful puerto rico or
taking a walk down the beach earlier
today with my wife nina and we're
supposed to film but the the sound on
the beach is crazy hopefully you can
still hear it here still got some wind
but on the water it's a crazy windy day
so we came back up the film
and as i was walking to the quick
instagram video
of just my feet in the sand and somebody
dm me as a response to say man
if i was there i have a really hard time
focusing on work
and i responded
i can't wait to get back to my room to
go film
like this is beautiful i love it it's
amazing right like what a scenery i'm
blessed to be here grateful that i can
have the kind of business that allows me
to travel and see these awesome places
but i love the work
i love working i love making videos for
you guys i can't wait to plan you know
the next week the next month the next
quarter for what i'm gonna be doing in
my business i love it
after i'm done filming you know what
we're going to do we're going to go down
on the beach we're going to go down
there see those see those see those
chairs right there we're going to go
down there
nina's going to work on her tan
probably pass out that's the goal she
wants to try to sleep i'm going to be
working i'm going to be working i'm
going to be i'm going to be looking at
my youtube stats i'm going to be
planning my membership course i'm going
to be looking at my youtube growth boot
camp i'm going to be working on the book
launch i'm going to be working and i
love it
i love it and that's weird that's not
what that's not what most of these
people want to do right that's not what
that's not what these guys want to do
that's not what but most people come to
a place like this
to escape a life that they hate
they come to a place like this for a
couple days or for a week to escape a
life that they hate they can run away
that's when i lie on the beach and
forget my life
forget that that world exists and just
escape
i think there's a huge mistake there's
nothing wrong if you love the beach you
love the ocean you love the weather it's
beautiful weather coming from toronto
canada we're buried under snow right now
so this is beautiful weather there's
nothing wrong with that
but what's better is fixing your life
if you're looking forward to your next
vacation that's amazing because you're
looking forward to it but not because
you're trying to run away from something
and that's what most people are doing
that's what most people are doing to run
away from a life that they hate
it's not the path and these are the
people whose opinions you're worried
about
the people who wake up every day go to a
job that they hate so that once a year
they can come on a vacation like this
are telling you
that you suck that you're crazy that you
shouldn't be doing this crazy thing
they gave up on their dreams years ago
don't let that infect you and it's not
that they suck and that you need to put
them down
but you can't let that toxicity seep
into yourself
[Music]
if you want to watch another top 10
rules of evan carl michael check out the
video next to me i think you're going to
enjoy continuity i will see you there
the 595 rule five percent of your time
thinking planning strategizing and 95 of
your time actually doing this is where a
lot of entrepreneurs get held up because